وقد تكثف القصف الاسرائيلي في الساعات
الاخيره على خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه
ونشاهد هذه الصور التي جاءتنا قبل قليل من
خان يونس وتظهر تصاعد اعمده
[موسيقى]
الدخان معنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في در
البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام لو
تضعنا في اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
وانسانيا في غزه هذا
الصباح المشهد هو قصف مستمر ومتواصل من
الدبابات الاسرائيليه ومن الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي تنفذ ما بين
الفينه والاخرى سلسله من الغارات العنيفه
لكن هذه الغارات تتركز في هذه اللحظات في
المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه خان يونس وايضا في
حي الشجاعيه وكذلك في منطقه جباليه وبيت
لاهيه التي تتعرض منذ عده ايام الى قصف
عنيف من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه تنفذ احزمه
ناريه منذ عده ايام في جباليا بلده جباليا
وايضا مخيم جباليا بيت لاهيه وايضا بيت
حانون وهذه المناطق تعرضت وتتعرض وما زالت
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه فيما يواصل جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي محاصرته لبعض المناطق لا سما
النقطه الطبيه التابعه للهلال الاحمر في
جباليا ك ذلك محاصرته لمستشفى العوده في
تل الزعتر في جباليا كذلك استمراره في قصف
المناطق مخيم جباليا وبلده جباليا قصف
المنازل المدنيه الماهوله بالسكان
وبالتالي هناك عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى
يوميا جراء استمرار هذا القصف الاسرائيلي
باتت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في
جباليه تركز قصفها على مربعات سكنيه
وبالتالي هذه المربعات هي مربعات ماهوله
بالسكان الناس تصر على البقاء في منازلها
وتلجا الى منازل الاقارب والجيران لكن
يلاحقهم القصف الاسرائيلي ويقصف وينسف هذه
المنازل على رؤوس هؤلاء السكان ويقتلهم
ويصيب العشرات في ظل عدم وجود رعايه صحيه
وفي ظل خروج جميع مستشفيات شمال قطاع غزه
عن الخدمه وبالتالي من يصاب يبقى على
الارض ينزف حتى الموت في الشجاعيه الاوضاع
ايضا تزداد خطوره في ظل استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي على تلك المناطق حي التفاح وحي
الشجاعيه وايضا كذلك حي درج تعرضوا الى
قصف عنيف من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
وجل الاستهدافات من الطائرات كانت لمنازل
مدنيه فلسطينيه وتم تدمير عدد كبير من
المنازل لا سما في حي الشجاعيه الذي يسته
الذي يشهد في هذه الاثناء قصف عنيف من
الطائرات وايضا من المدف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لا سما الدبابات الاسرائيليه
المتمركزه شرق حي الشجاعيه وايضا في الغرب
وبالتالي حي الشجاعيه بات محاصرا لا
تستطيع سيارات اسعاف لا ت يستطيع طواقم
دفاع مدني الوصول الى هذا الحي وانتشال
الجثامين واجلاء الجرحى وبالتالي عندما
يتراجع جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من بعض
المناطق تعمل طواقم الدفاع المدني وطواقم
الاسعاف على الذهاب والتوجه الى تلك
المناطق وتنتشل عشرات من الجثامين كما جرى
في حي الصبره بالامس عندما توجهت سيارات
الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع المدني الى حي
الصبره عند تراجع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من اطراف هذا الحي وانتشلت
عشرات جثامين من عائلات واحده بالتالي
القصف الاسرائيلي مركز في هذه اللحظات على
هذه الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه غزه في وسط
القطاع ايضا نفذت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه سلسله من الغارات الساعات
الماضيه ولكن حتى الان لم تصل اي اصابات
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وربما هذا ناجم
عن صعوبه الوصول الى تلك الاماكن لا لا
سما وان القصف كان يستهدف شرق مخيم البريج
شرق او شمال مخيم النصيرات وهذه المناطق
ما زالت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لا سما منطقه المغرا التي تم
انتشال جثماني شهيدين بالامس من جراء
القصف الاسرائيلي بصعوبه وصلت سياره
الاسعاف الى تلك المناطق وانتشلت هذهه
الجثامين الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى هنا في
وسط القطاع خانيونس الاوضاع تزداد خطوره
لاسما وان القصف بات يقترب اكثر فاكثر من
وسط او قلب مدينه خانيونس او حتى بالقرب
من مستشفى ناصر في مدينه خانيونس القصف
الا اسرائيلي مركز على الاحياء الشرقيه
منطقه بن سيلا وخزاعه والقرار ومعن وعبس
والزن وهذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ومن الطائرات
الطائرات تستهدف منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
تقتل السكان الذين ما زالوا يتواجدون في
هذه المنازل وتحاصر هذه المناطق وتمنع
ايضا وصول سيارات الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع
المدني بالتالي من يصاب في تلك المناطق لا
يستطيع الوصول حتى الى النقاط الطبيه التي
يمكن ان تكون قريبه من هذا المكان مستشفى
الاوروبي في مدينه خانيونس لا يبعد سوى
عده امتار عن هذه المناطق التي تتعرض الى
القصف ولكن حتى السكان لا يستطيعون الخروج
من هذه المناطق واجلاء الجرحى واجلاء
وانتشال الجثامين واخراجها والتوجه الى
المستشفيات وبالتالي الاوضاع تزداد كارثيه
في تلك المناطق شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من دير البلح